did you spot the giant floating baby
head what about nosey the lake nose
monster
because they both made cameos in phineas
and ferb's newest movie
candace against the universe is like a
montage of phineas and ferb's greatest
hits
enjoy the ride from the very first
roller coaster they ever built two
others
the movie is packed with cameos by some
of our favorite recurring characters
like paul the delivery guy and
references to iconic episodes like the
time when they carved candace's head
into mount rushmore
but don't worry if you weren't able to
catch them all because we have the 15
best ones right here
in the opening number ironically called
such a beautiful day
candace rattles off some of the craziest
things her brothers have ever done
the references go all the way back to
the very first episode of the series
when phineas and ferb made a roller
coaster in their backyard
do you like it and that time they made a
robot version of themselves
but candace also mentions events from
episodes when she wasn't around to catch
her brothers in the act
like the paper pelican that she didn't
see because she was at jeremy's pool
party
she also wasn't around to see the
pyramid-related sports because the boys
went to the park for that one
did she hear about their adventures from
the boys themselves or did her
frustration at her brothers help her
break the fourth wall as she took a
not-so-happy ride down memory lane
one of phineas and ferb's most popular
tunes is busted which debuted
on the ice cream you scream as a duet
between candace and vanessa
see the doofenshmirtz while the girls
aren't actually together
their separate performances are combined
as candace complains about her brothers
and vanessa complains about her father
there's a quick callback to this duet in
the movie when the duo
almost sings together before vanessa
makes candace come to her senses
once the music stops she asks what we're
all thinking
wait why do i have a guitar
one of the best moments from the movie
is when the chicken replacenator steals
a chicken from a farm on earth and sends
a dragon in its place
it switched places with the nearest
chicken wherever that is
but the farmer and his wife who received
the dragon luckily just in time for
their dragon theme park to open have
appeared in quite a few phineas and ferb
episodes
they've been the victims of termites
falling bunnies and vans
[Music]
not one word and multiplying monkeys
thankfully they usually get exactly what
they need before moving on to the
farmer's next
crazy business idea looks like somebody
owes me an apology
candace against the universe gave us an
intergalactic prize
in the form of the full version of the
iconic space adventure song
before the movie we'd only heard
snippets of the jingle to the star trek
inspired movie and television show which
is pretty straightforward
[Music]
it's an adventure in space now thanks to
belgian and his obsession
we know the song really does have a full
version and it's even on the film's
official soundtrack
[Applause]
we all know doofenshmirtz is his own
worst enemy at times so of course the
movie had to make room for a quick cameo
from one of his favorite things
a self-destruct button he doesn't
actually use it this time but as he's
trying to figure out a way out of a
sticky situation
he pulls out an axinator that has a
self-destruct button
right on the back why would an axe need
a self-destruct button
only doofenshmirtz himself can explain
that logic
speaking of inators you might remember
that the chicken replacemator is not a
new invention
thanks to my brand new chicken
replacement
when it first appeared in the what a
crock episode when dr doofenshmirtz
tries to embarrass his brother roger by
replacing his mayoral award with a
chicken
but now it's a handheld device and it
turns out doofenshmirtz was entirely
right about it being better to replace
something with a chicken
than to not replace it with a chicken
his chicken transferring device
ends up saving the day it was a good
call adding a furthest chicken option
when aliens enter the stadium we get a
lot of cameos from characters who have
been featured on the tv series
if you look carefully at the audience
you can spot mishti baljit's long-lost
friend and crush
clyve addison the famed special effects
guru behind the space adventure movies
and paul the delivery guy who often
brings phineas and ferb material for
their crazy projects
there's also a woman with a lot of
concern for her watermelon
this is a running gag on the show with
people often yelling
off screen during times of chaos here we
get to see a watermelon loving woman
freak out over her favorite fruit as
aliens descend upon the stadium another
great cameo happens during candace's
opening song when a trio of
shaggy-haired musicians
shows up to provide some stylish backup
vocals these musicians
have shown up in a few phineas and ferb
episodes to help out musically the most
notable
is in the episode it's about time where
they help doofenshmirtz out as he sings
my nemesis
a tribute to the one and only perry the
platypus
there are a lot of quick visual
references to some of the show's best
running gags in the form of billboards
at the stadium there's a banner
advertising ducky momo
the japanese children show that candice
loves
the logo for love handle the popular
band that has shown up a few times and
even performed paul the delivery guys
theme music
and a billboard for scenic lake nose
where the boys once had to rescue a
friendly monster named nosy from another
one of doofenshmirtz
evil plots there's also the giant
floating baby head which
inexplicably turns up in a lot of
episodes
when phineas and ferb realize candace is
upset with them they try to think of
what they could do to make her feel
better that'll be more permanent than
the time they carved her head
into mount rushmore this happened in the
episode candace loses her head and while
candace liked the memorial
it didn't take long for it to crumble to
pieces right before her mom sees what
her brothers have been up to of course
the mug they go with as her new gift
complete with flashbacks of the siblings
time together
seems to be a much better choice for
their older sister
when phineas and ferb run to baljeet for
help getting to candace he suggests a
portal to get them to space
this is a reference to when he made a
portal to try and go to mars in the
episode
unfair science fair neither of these
portals worked as they were intended to
so it looks like belgian still has some
work to do if he wants to achieve
easy space travel huge phineas and ferb
fans probably know that
milo's murphy's law was created by the
same people who gave us phineas and ferb
and the two stories take place in the
same universe of course they weren't
going to waste a chance to make a
crossover reference in candace against
the universe when candace asks the
spaceship to stop stop stop the system
mishears it as
chop chop by the lumberjack and please
chop away at my heart by the lumber's
axe which was originally performed in
the milo murphy's law
episode secrets and pies
phineas and ferb is full of weird silly
downright
hilarious names for things the best
silly names used in candace against the
universe
are probably the planet fliblaut in the
roblot cluster
but fliblaut isn't nearly as random of a
name as it sounds
if you flip it around it sounds like too
all beef which is how the recipe to a
big mac starts with two all beef patties
the planet itself
also kind of looks like a burger patty
so we can see exactly where they got
their inspiration from
in our language candace is the noise
someone makes when they explode from the
waist up the voice behind the sound
someone makes when they explode from the
waist up
actually belongs to a phineas and ferb
superfan and yes
saying candace over and over again was
her only role in the movie
it's tiffany haddish who said she asked
for a perry the platypus t-shirt in
exchange for using her voice in the
movie
sadly they don't make them anymore but
the showrunners did
hand paint some perry designs on some
nice t-shirts for her
so at least they're unique if you're
wondering where
exactly this phineas and ferb movie
falls into the series timeline candace's
opening song
is a good place to look it sounds like
the movie is set in the same summer as
the majority of the episodes she sings
about
and likely takes place right after troy
story it definitely takes place before
last day of summer
and night of the living pharmacists but
why does traveling to space
and candace's newfound bond with her
brothers never come up later in the show
it looks like it's because they found
out about perry's secret identity
at the very end of the movie they all
look towards the platypus as his
communicator goes off
outing him to his host family and their
friends a little brain zapping later and
perry probably had their memories wiped
of the whole ordeal
what other easter eggs and references
did you spot let us know your favorite
ones in the comments section down below
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more great
stuff
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time